[Music]
welcome back Republicans claim new
internal FDA Communications revealed
that the Biden Administration may have
tried to cut corners on coveted vaccine
approval an email from 2021 shows the
FDA director of office director of
office of vaccines and research warning
quote a review that is hyper accelerated
beyond the already very rapid September
15th Target date may be less thorough
than our typical review Texas
Congressman Ronnie Jackson is
investigating this on the house select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
and he joins us now Congressman doctor
thanks for joining us I know you've had
a lot of work in this explain to us what
we're seeing here
well thanks Joe well the biggest thing
here is that the Republicans have the
majority now we do have the the select
committee on chronovirus to be started
we're starting to get access to a lot of
emails we didn't have we have
whistleblowers and witnesses that are
coming forward and one of the things
that we're discovering here is the
vaccine approval process and the fight
Administration may have been driven for
political reasons not for safety reasons
what we see is that the the Pfizer had
requested a an approval process for full
approval of their vaccine because it or
remember up until that point it was
being used kind of an experimental
status uh under emergency use
authorization they wanted full approval
they applied for that in May of 2021.
this is an approval process that
normally takes 10 to 12 months in July
July 16 of 2021 the FDF came back and
said we will give you an approval we
will start the approval process and we
will expedite it so that they could do
it potentially in six months which is
the shortest period possible right and
so they had a stated approval date of
January of 2022 well privately we see
these emails where they're saying they
want it approved by September of 2021
which was way faster four months faster
than the expedited approval process and
eight months faster than the standard
process well there were people like Dr
Gruber who like you said was the
director of the vaccine uh the vaccine
research and and stepped that program
that was that was responsible for
approving it she was running that
program she and other members of the FDA
were up in arms and we saw these emails
where they're bantering back and forth
and they're saying hey this is not safe
remember this is a vaccine that was uh
being used under brand new technology we
had tons of data coming in tons and tons
of data we had a lot of reports of
vaccine related injury and side effects
that were coming in so this was a
behemoth of a request anyway just to
look at all this information if if it's
true that this was sped up in kind of It
kind of alludes to that in saying we
can't do it we can't speed it up anymore
which means it was sped up at some point
who sped it up
well the Biden Administration sped it up
people from the EOP were pushing the
people from the EOP were pushing people
at the FDA Dr Gruber actually resigned
in protest because she said this is not
this is not how this process is supposed
to work we cannot review all this
information in this short period of time
it's unsafe and Joey they had set the
date for January of 2022. mind you the
process didn't even start until July 16
of 2021 and after Dr Gruber left you
know when they approved it they approved
it in August 23rd of 2021 five weeks
after it started five weeks after the
process it was approved in five weeks it
was supposed to take you know initially
10 to 12 months and then six months with
the expedited process here's the kicker
why did they do that because they had
been talking for some period of time
about vaccine mandates the Biden
Administration knew that they were gonna
have a real problem trying to push
vaccine mandates using a vaccine that
was being administered under emergency
use authorization they aren't even
talking about the military about uh you
know health care workers and so that's
what they did the day after it was
approved approved on the August the 24th
DOD secretary mandated it for all
members of the military and CMS followed
right after that this there's a lot here
well it's hard to believe it's going to
take decades for the American people or
even Congress in at large to see all all
of this information and how this vaccine
was approved I know that you've been
grilling on that hopefully that's not
the case there's a bill going to the
president now to get truth behind uh
behind some of the origins of covid
hopefully the work that Republicans are
doing in the house gets more of that
transparency out Dr Congressman Ronnie
Jackson thank you so much for joining us
thank you for the work you're doing
thank you Joe I appreciate it yes sir
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis